I don't know wild uh yeah we're good I
know there's some water for you too
buddy if you get thirsty it's high it's
our hot breath water that's that's my
gift to you cuz it's all uh all on brand
so thanks for doing this man thank you
for having me man I appreciate it yeah
this is hot breath that's why it says it
but something more lighter
well last the last interview it just
happened just happened
you just got ambushed by TMZ just got
ambushed by t ZM t as I put in my films
I like make one of my buddies am T when
I write my movies up with ZM t they
can't get me what does that happen to
you a lot no I mean not with like deep
questions of like socio-political stuff
I'm like you know I mean I'm a real dude
I'm gonna say what I feel but at the
same time it's like like ask me about
what I got on yeah what do you believe
about I might yo you should plug that
you should plug the Kingdom gear I know
yeah it's out there yeah shout out to
the gear we can we can listen we getting
done man we listen we it's been a long
journey actually two years long we're
getting done the kingdom of everything
axes Kingdom clothing right here hmm I
just you know we we should be dressed
like like like who we are and everything
so I just feel like you know just just
one of those things like be different
too I don't like to look like anybody
else I like to look different from
everybody else I got my own style or
like every time people Jack my style
kind of switch it up and everything's
people were jock in the leather and then
you had to switch it up I was another
King have leather condom i was the
leather king back in the day now you got
gear i mean
the kingdom let's yeah he's a whole the
kingdom clothing in the kingdom over
everything yes yes your research of
course yes we found a way to make like I
can't say yeah we got some some good
brew for you come let you try some of
our brew yeah it's not coffee as brew is
that is that the nice reppin C's well
yeah we'd make sure you know it's not
coffee as brew it's the best brew in the
world no crash nothing twice the energy
of coffee that's legal oh yeah look it's
fairly good our secret ingredient
yes good it's so crazy to see like the
arc in your career yeah like me going
from the booty sweat guy to kingdom of
everything right now baby study the tree
and the branches I'm from and the seats
and I'm from it makes all sense
well even your dad was here that he has
a clothing store doesn't mean back in
like 99 it's funny even because he was a
pastor your grandfather was also yeah
with 27 generations of Levitical priests
I should say is that what you're getting
no I miss you I am is I'm to get into
nothing it's in my blood it's like you
know it's like you know you know you
look at certain people like Steph Curry
like stuff you look at Steph Curry's the
ballplayers father but it's in your
blood it was like a cold you know DNA is
your coding is what it is you know we
served my family we served the father of
generations and generations and I was
first want to go to Hollywood and kind
of make a career you know but at the
same time you always gonna come back to
who you are you know so this is mr.
booty sweat was that part of who you
were it was good we had good times back
then you know of course so you know yeah
it was part of the journey definitely
man I bet Muhammad Ali Lou momily he was
Cassius Clay and you know when he got
enlightened in his faith he became mom
and I leave which I will say made his
story even greater if he was always
Cassius Clay I don't think it even made
you know a um a rumble it's part of
people story then the enlightening side
of it as always people part of people
stories oh yeah and part of your story
is you were in the machine-like
headfirst all the way in yeah the
machines
kind of like Moses so like well I cuz in
researching you it's you didn't really
go into too much detail about that point
in your life it was more just like
here's some cool stories but like one
thing I heard you mention is in Big
Momma's House hmm you wore that you wore
the dress yeah and you said like after
that it was like five years of hell
seven seven years of hell five ish so
what
go into more detail on that what was
that hell well for me I came crashing
down you know people call the string of
bad luck but you know I'm leaving the
coincidences so I think of the father
was trying to chastise me to show me you
know where I need to be at you know for
his purpose in my life so so that like
there weren't any more jobs after that
or no I was big enough forget the job
cycle I mean they would actually offer
me things and therefore stuff I couldn't
make you know it wasn't even my my whole
state of being wasn't at peace you know
wasn't even about the jobs about
everyday life people will say string of
bad luck the best way I could say in the
language of Chin's house the best way I
can say it is is a string of that look
so how low did it get pretty low was the
rock bottom read job yeah man me man is
it means Who I am I can't deny it you
know I was talking to him the guy out
there he said he just you know some
people feel like that's what they are
you know like you know you can't tell a
person who's who is say for example this
lady who know the news she says she
feels like he's a black woman inside she
feel that's what she connects to mm-hmm
you know for me I can't speak or judge
her I can say that for me I know what I
feel inside and what compels me you know
yeah and what is that the word of the
Living God of yahuwah elohim and that's
just who I am
you know it's Who I am well I fight it
you know is that
within all of us and we a lot of us just
suppress it's up to you everyone's
journey is a journey
everyone's journey to journey so you
can't I can't put my journey on you you
kept your journey I mean you have your
own story so you know yeah and you like
to differentiate like your path from
like church or religion yeah like
there's no culture difference big
difference so is that that gets lost in
I think the Bible is real I think the
religions are fake that's what I what is
these records were taken by organization
you don't it's like if I take hip hop
and I'm making it religion to put jay-z
on the cross you know what I mean you
know it's like that was a culture of
people that did things you know you take
the culture people that did things mean
you make it a religion for you know
money and fame you take any story and
say hey you want to hear the story come
seeing here you know so so it's kind of
like each religion is almost its own
remix of the same story well I'm here to
speak my religion I'm Sam from from from
a perspective what I know it was a
culture of people the stories about a
certain people who went through went
through certain things and that was a
story not if I take these Scrolls and I
put them together and I and you know say
hey guys if you want to hear these crows
come pay this building you know so how
is this affected like your stand-up
nothing I'm hilarious um it actually
made me funnier that's what I meant like
your material or how your well I don't
get too deep into this with my material
but I do represent Who I am as the
person you know mm-hmm are you yeah as a
person what I mean by ads my everyday
experiences in life right you got you
not supposed be overly much righteous
where you can't have experiences of life
we have experiences right I my point of
view but the now I have experiences we
go through I go through everything
everyone else goes through pretty for
the most part you know we go through
relationships good and bad you know this
is life life's a story you know yeah
this seems to give this whole other give
this comedy side and then this whole
other almost side you're it's all the
same pushing up yeah it's all the same
person is just as layers you know what I
mean
it's like you just be who you are that's
the thing when people understand one you
who you are is it just be it you don't
have to like try and be like yeah I'm to
try to be something I'm not
I didn't chose choose this five chose me
yeah I think especially with comedians
we can almost get so caught up in the
single dimension of being a comedian
that we forget to become that worth like
a three speaks a lot of truth on stage
but he doesn't in a funny way so his
troupe that he sees is true he speaks
and a guy out there everyone has an
opportunity to speak what they what they
want mm-hmm there's nothing wrong with
it every human has to solve them real
well you know you have your will to do
what you want so I'm not here to speak
for your will that's obvious in a guy
out there you know everybody has a right
at least yeah choice yeah so for me III
speak from a place where it's it's true
to me you see so like Trump for instance
you did Trump material tonight yeah so I
guess that's an extreme example of
somebody Trump Obama everybody doesn't
matter might a Democrat a Republican
yeah yeah I'm just just I can make fun
everybody did he did he go to your dad's
Church yeah
and your dad spoke at his inauguration
yeah me at my dad's career as a
potentially what he's doing is it's
something I asked him about I personally
you know was was was I wasn't I have my
thoughts on it you know what was his for
what was the intentions of it why did
why the heat why'd he come here you know
um I don't know you know that's my dad's
career I mean dad can ask me about my
jokes I can ask him I felt compelled to
to do that but I I have my thoughts on
it you know and what are those well my
thoughts are just like it's like you
know what's what like what someone's
intention are you doing this to get
photo ops 2 black people or you or you
or the general community right so yeah
you'd probably thinks he's just the
photo ops
well he doesn't done nothing from the
items didn't really done anything for
our people you know
I don't I don't see that so only time
would tell I can't say he's not but he
has not anything so so my thoughts
staying true at this point it seems like
with how the world and I've heard you
talk about this on stage to it like it's
almost like the world is ending so it
seems like the world almost needs comedy
more than ever and I any truth truth
more than ever comedy right comedians
are up there just on their soapbox
like cool it again would have been like
sorry it's it's in focus so it shows
when peak focus is well it won't show up
on the act this won't be blue lowing you
know no that's just the display for
anybody who's behind the camera that you
keep boy it'll it'll cut in and out
don't about okay guy chain nice but that
the listeners yeah I get about 1,500 a
week nice oh yeah shut out it's really a
it's a comedy mastery podcast so it's
more about interviewing comedians about
the craft of comedy in there which is
I'm fine with it just keeps it's not
like I'm you know I'm not mad about it
it's just like my colleague is that my
commies my comedy mm-hmm my thoughts and
my thoughts and um I pulled my everyday
experience in my comedy as you see so
yeah for sure yeah and even to get into
your creative side a little bit more
because it's was interesting you being
like this prodigy in a sense of it it's
16 you're in church doing Chris Rock
jokes and then by like 9 is it 19 yep
where you did a three-minute set at
Laugh Factory and then like those movies
later like what uh what was that what
was that set
like who saw you or what was that moment
it was yeah that's why I know I you know
I always felt like I had something else
pulling me you know so I think was part
of the story you know that had to happen
no one else has done that since its
Maddie or it yes the reason why I feel
like is not there now I'm at the next
phase in my life right you know I think
I'm at a place in my life where I'm
doing things more meaningful for the
world in society something like I would
put anything out there you know if you
want to put junk on everything you know
or open up the hole more instead of
patching it up you know I'm saying so
I'm a patch I'm a patch your upper so
what happened to my major Robert was
there an agent in the audience um yeah
it was agent from from CAA oh snap boys
the big boys yeah that's your female and
she was name was Elena to coast yes well
I thought you were Tamara now yes yeah
she's been on here she's been on here as
well I interviewed her when we were out
in LA and you getting into really Tropic
Thunder I had two things I just wanted
to touch on with it um the first you
working with Robert Downey jr. in
blackface as a method actor back then
that movie was I mean still funny but
I'm saying back then it was not like now
with Trump in office if he was dead
right now that just shows how polarizing
oh yeah I mean let's go so quickly
mmm-hmm yeah Emily with a great great
experience but then we would not have
would not work right now it's a they
right now
but did you ever get did you ever get
offended or like I mean you just sing
like a white guy in blackface you know
it's so funny because I did grow up
thinking that we're all equal you know
so for me it wasn't offensive I thought
it's like fun but than Austin I did the
history of blackface also wait a minute
you know it's offense I was 2200 that
film you weren't thinking about right
kids don't see race like that you know
they don't see different nations like
that I guess when you get older you get
programs right start to see nations and
a certain way and I do believe every
nation is different every nation has
their greatness to it and but at the
time I wasn't seeing it and I was trying
to have fun you know no don't hit on my
wait a minute what do you mean you
people you know me so that's where that
line came from I start to kind of like
look what do you mean you like what do
you mean me that line was like an improv
and he was just walking around set like
that right what about being under the
the helm of Ben Stiller like what was
that a great college I think that was a
college oh yeah that was a great College
for me so I learned a lot from Ben and I
told Ben I was like Ben I learned so
much from you girl let me stop hope I
didn't do much I never forget the face
yeah like Ben I learned so much from he
was like yeah now he cool I miss being
stupid I think it was stress so the
90,000,000 are moving right I'm having
hot breath a we out your font asada yes
yeah that's her that's a sponsor really
doing blue mountain spring water that's
good a give you a breath one breath at a
time so what did you specifically learn
from him from Ben
I mean he's great filmmaking he's a
filmmaker Ben's record people know him
as an actor he's a filmmaker
concentrator very hard to do so he like
specifics about like his work ethic
I think is amazing playing an aerial
unreal but your honor you're on a 90
million dollar movie like this isn't
Roll Bounce you know like this is a
tough movie to believe it's not you know
really being on rollerskates but but 90
million like you're looking at them
you're looking at like blockbuster yeah
most people on the planet don't even get
to be on set for something like that
yeah so even like it was a great great
ride man I'm starting to learn that you
can do I learned that you could do more
with less - you don't need 90 million -
to do 90 million quality movies you just
need a great writer great producer that
are that's humble and want to make films
so the 90 million is like the hype like
90 million dollar comedy yeah and that
was big back then nowadays I mean I
guess more noise not even not a comedy
still don't exist nothing about it
exists so yeah
good times for all from all these movies
you you were in and a part of and now
you you have your own production company
and you're creating your own content
what were what were lessons you learned
from working on all those movies that
you carry over into your own personal
endeavors now just work work ethic um
shoot what you know at this point you
know I guess you got to shoot what you
want to write you were able to tell
stories as true to us and that's that's
that's what um being everyone else's I
would say movies are their what they're
envisioned helped me go okay now let me
envision when I see so yeah how do you
find out what you know like shoot what
you know how do you know it's like
creative writing they say write down you
know what's you would you like your
creative or do creative writing class I
just say to write what's in your mind is
express yourself this is that how your
writing starts is your most like free
write from well for me it writes with
the subs that I know you know so for me
I just write yeah yeah from from from
what I would I project what I know like
things I've been through you know mm-hm
or it comes from
just imagining like you know you tell
get out came from the mind of a key and
peele that the whole mindset of like of
like the way they think is is there is
their perspective that's what they call
in comedy perspective of course you know
in life you just project it you know but
to actually make it your own personal
thoughts make it universal to where it
will well I mean that's based off of you
know whatever you use onre your your
relatability but you learn it already we
know that everyone knows that you got to
be relatable to certain people sometimes
you you don't I think job dinner was
kind of real far left and I think it was
great it was written well yeah people
enjoyed it yeah it's almost it can be
absurd but it's got to have like it's
all how you say something interesting
you going to more detail on that yeah
[Music]
you cuz I kill you I want to kill you
but with the vibe of I want to kill you
because I love you people like many ways
so mad because I you know what you know
what I love you like a brother man
people it's just how you say things is
it's called you know uh what's wrong
look for is called um understand like
what's the word I'm looking for
it's the way you express yourself you
know energy behind it
yeah cuz I've noticed on stage that how
you say something can be the difference
between a laugh and I'm no yes yes very
much so
and that probably plays into finding
your voice on stage is you know what's
true to you how you talk
mm-hmm how you speak how you inflection
certain things it's all communication
are there certain techniques you've
developed refound oh that helps brings
joke more to life for that's all about
being on stage and doing that time yeah
so what are some of those techniques you
found for me you know I found it just I
mean I can't really even say it I just
got a feeling
mmm-hmm is a feeling so I can't believe
and say what I do I just kind of
Jackson and and feel what I'm saying
when you say project does that mean like
yours you're actually visualizing what
you're talking about
July's you can say it a certain way
projecting your voice certain way yeah
because what I noticed with yours also
is the amount of act outs you can do and
act out energy very up but I love your
commitment to it though like there's I
came here the one you did tonight is it
the donut where you like go until people
are kind of like one and then you keep
going and it brings them all back around
like Oh totally you just kept committing
to it and it was like ha they're like oh
he's still going and then like you still
going I feel like it was donut it's hard
to do it's hard where a TD crowds it's
hard to do he's dying from a TD what hot
water um cuz I had um I had Aries Spears
on here breaking down impersonations and
he talks about like he has like a
musical approach to how he does
impersonations what is your approach to
impersonations or just like developing
characters in general just taking real
life in Britain and taking what they do
and just act it out just take what they
do and just just take the references and
just do it it's not it's not really a
science to it so like specific things
they do or like are their personalities
like of somebody that's it you look at
them like oh okay
that's what that is your impression of
someone impression means okay see ya I
saw you did an interview where they
wanted you do some impression you're
like no I haven't studied that one so
they was like some Randolph they've
maybe like Terry Bradshaw it was
something random yeah you're like I
haven't studied that when I was like oh
I wonder how he studies people just look
at him watch just watch how they move as
it like you're studying me no I'm just
studying you I'm like trying to get as
much information as possible
how's the CIA interview well it's all
it's all the process you know yeah but I
did I did interview um you familiar with
85 South Show
of course cheddar Bray the producer yeah
I interviewed him and on YouTube so many
of the comments are like Oh white boy
trying to steal the black man's magic
and like all this stuff because I do ask
super in-depth questions yeah but it's
all for learning it's not like to
exploit someone or to I mean I one of my
favorite look at the Native Americans
like you know and the pilgrims I mean I
look I know I look like the white devil
but but I'm all about just learning from
as many people as possible which is what
this podcast is about ya know I'm guilty
[Laughter]
I'm like feeling better see how does it
grow but it's like you know you can all
have the same recipe but it's not the
same cook you know you just like take it
one day at a time and really talk fake
really talk big you do do a good job of
that you just a lot of practice nice
look I just do it on purpose just to see
how far you dig serving you dah
how am i doing how's the digging did you
do it good okay
you got you got one foot I got one foot
you're doing great at begging like yeah
I mean I learned so much from been
stewing like what you learn you like you
know just movies he's just been you know
and then more movies I think he's a guy
oh yeah he's been yeah but you you mean
you said it cuz that's been that been
happened do you get it
so in happen so happens when it been
happen you got to move forward to the
future oh but you all but your current
your reality is based on your previous
experiences yes because that was a
banner so what did you learn from him
that now impacts what you're doing
through that it's full name is Ben
man is it that was yes Ben is the son of
Ben and which means son so Ben so is the
Illuminati real you want to give vague
let's get direct what do you fill out
loominatee exactly I don't know what is
it what is Illuminati what is it with
these videos on YouTube
what's Illuminati well I guess one
example is having black men wear dresses
that's supposed to be a bar no white
white dresses - how was it the
loominatee well the controversy alleged
this is what a Dave Chappelle
yes okay yeah yeah which I mean anything
he says I'm I'm like I'm not blindly on
board but like his opinions come from no
no knocking Dave I'm trying to see where
did this come from
yes so that's that was that's the only
exposure I've had to that kind of point
of view of the Illuminati is having
black men wear dresses but like you said
white men as well but it seems to be
well you came from I think it came from
ancient Greece the dress like the togas
yeah but like you know back in they
where men do plays and dress okay yeah
your nation my nation I think I'm your
opinion I don't know is that Greek is
Greek
I'm not that whoa different nations okay
the Greeks and the Romans and the
Europeans as you say from that viewpoint
of Rome Rome an romanticizing Roman
right to a theater that was theater
mm-hmm and now and and now this is this
is this was derivative from the European
nations we weren't as people of
different nations we our nation was
never doing that we learned that from
you guys or
Europeans savages I mean I I know the
factory with your Haney that's the
problem about America you say fax and
you're hating know you're not hating
you're stating the facts
well but there's another one look at
their ancestors in the mirror this
happened it's not like it's like you
know what is true is like okay we go all
day with this like okay I'm not sitting
here right now talking to you on a mic
you know I mean so when you look at it
from a perspective of what's true it's
like we have these facts and and
artifacts that show you know and and and
and books of the Iliad and these these
Grecian books and these different
societies that learned you know how to
do the arts and different things from
the culture and was brought and mixed
into different cultures so the
Illuminati mm-hmm I mean were there they
are they are they are they what nation
are you from that's what I'm asking you
I don't ever met it in the machine you
yeah but I never went a little ice white
[ __ ] like I don't know you know okay you
never went that far
I mean I'll probably have more money I
probably would still be on the cover of
a lottery ticket I don't know if that's
the case I don't think it's more so a
same thing I think of just understanding
compromise and what would you do to do
what would you do to be famous no was
there a moment like that in your career
where you had to step away what do you
mean well like like Dave Chappelle's
moment where he was like yeah what was
the moment that made you do the pivot
well I just realize that you know
Hollywood at this point at the time that
I was in it wasn't for the the mellah
native man so but now every not now we
all on TV member I was working when it
wasn't hot you know what it wasn't cool
to be you know I wasn't I came in the
middle of like okay all there's nine
these guys and then there was like me
and then everyone else
came after so what were you experiencing
that made you feel like Hollywood was
not forth as you said the melon ated man
because at the time right different now
because I mean everyone it's like at
this point after different TV shows
black-ish shows it's cool to be a
leading mela native man that's good yeah
now so what was it like um it was more
so you have to always be the second the
best friend you could never lead yeah
well yeah you know now they're like they
have Denzel of course in Will Smith at
the time now I was like yeah Michael B
Jordan you have Anthony Anderson you
have more male lead yeah but it wasn't
like that when I was working did you
experience like any prejudice while you
were in Hollywood not prejudice like
that is just I think everyone's
programmed to to do it in a formulaic
way of what they feel is safe for them
yeah I'm predictable yeah well safer for
people who needs to feel safe yeah cuz
you hear the Hollywood studios almost
just want to kind of reinvent the wheel
every time whatever works just keep
doing that over and over and over it
again so the black guy next to the white
guy you know put the black guy in the
back you know yeah so what happened to
make it to now it's cool for the black
got to be the lead proven proven shows
of improvements to work okay well I
didn't know based on your experience
though I mean I didn't I haven't rode
that wave I've been on major network TV
and the long huh so what made you step
away well I think Hollywood realized
that you know I was more of a free
thinker than a person who who can just
do whatever no
so that can scare them sometimes I feel
I can scare people if you have your own
opinions but that's not a Perry even a
free thinker he was like look I'm gonna
put these movies out so it could be a
good thing to so for you you were a
little more outspoken or not is just no
I just
people could just tell when you're like
this is like they can feel it you people
could feel when you're you're not happy
or you're just like it's not oh this is
not what I envisioned no my image to be
so yeah so you just stopped getting work
or you know I mean necessarily know I
kind of more so turned down a lot of
stuff and because I did you know then
you can you get labeled hard to work it
when you don't want to do what they say
to do so you got that label no I don't
know about so you can be label hard to
work well and if I do have a label it
doesn't matter they don't they don't
control my career anyways you know my
career is is is this is the movie you
know you don't have to go on to film
every everyone's famous now you got a
camera when I want to be on TV
go get your phone you know yeah that's
that's the new wave - is the wave is
where everybody is almost there almost
their own network no yeah just what you
do with that platform exactly and you're
kind of building a whole production
company yeah we're working faith-based
films getting more everything
productions that's what we're doing and
what it's like in 100 million homes that
were you oh no that's that's my dad's
Network yeah Oh your dad's Network yeah
we're not a homes yeah and what's that
one called impact network impact network
yes as we're being probed for your your
your CIA agents are you do you think I'm
a CIA now you think so what why would
they watch this no because because they
would it would make sense who has time
to just watch CIA people learn of course
easy man do you do you believe in like
tall graves and stuff like that what's
that aliens that are walking the earth
yeah yeah there there are aliens
definitely their home yes big deal
anymore oh but just there's the people
that think they're actually walking the
earth now like amongst us bro I guess if
you may because I read the ancient
scrolls they are oh but I mean this is
nothing
a new of like it's all in the Bible the
Bible talks about aliens I mean oh yeah
yes read it Wow okay very easy no one
reads it you just go no one reads it no
no one reads it these are old scrolls
yeah it's late y'all late with this it's
been going on well a common phrase is
that history repeats itself
so what are we repeating right now word
I think we repeating the days of Noah so
shall it be as was in the days of Noah
so shall it be how much time do we have
[Laughter]
well I'm like well I can't really get
any comedy techniques out of them maybe
I can get the future of human humanity
out of them because you have been
prophetic you've been known to be
prophetic how you know you said in an
interview yeah yes my mama was when she
was she when she birthed me you know
yeah that's my mom who I was when she
birthed me that's the best way to find
out
who what was she birthing out Yvonne no
my mom oh okay I thought your mom's name
you give on you know remember oh my bad
oh my bad I got her middle name sorry
Alexander Alexander my middle name yeah
what does Alexander mean well
interviewer did I say I was prophetic I
think it's a radio interview you didn't
maybe where you're talking about Oh dig
you're doing a radio interview talking
about
well Kingdom Cafe but you're talking
about it was around when the Starbucks
thing was happening yeah and you were
like yeah I predicted this and then that
you said you've been known to be
prophetic that's my mama
all right I'll text her I'll DM her
prior don't when when you Bertha what
what would you see who the guy tell you
he was so you're who this is heavy man
so you're you're important like you're
you're here to actually you're here to
actually impact the world in a major way
chosen all these things is you're saying
these things I've not said anything like
this to you oh I know I'm inquiring I'm
I'm asking you ever heard the one when
Peter when Christ asked Peter he said
Peter who do they say I am and Peter
answers on answered his question he
answered he answered his own question so
I'm the chosen one
no he answered the question which is
what he was asking and what's the chosen
what's that mean I'm saying he answered
the question so he said we say you're a
son of Living God so only I didn't tell
you that mmm he answered you said
something that I never even said
anything to you about you said these
things I'd say right you inspired me to
say it I didn't spire you say nothing
I'm saying you said it I'm just trying
not to be vague understanding you just
said something that I never implied
right so what thought how gave you that
thought you being prophetic no I'm Sam
but you said something else though you
said you said something about being
chosen or I never said anything like
that once those words never came out of
my mouth but do you think we all are no
no okay now we all play a part in this
whole thing but weren't chosen to do
something this has been the wildest
interviews about comedy I know he wins
in the background everything every time
I spell comedy
[Laughter]
I imagine in deflecting on himself I'm
just bearing myself well every time I
ask about comedy go back I said my
techniques yeah but hey it's alright
don't worry about it it's fine we got a
lot of we got a lot out of this it's
good was that vague I feel like I was I
feel like I was like like my comedy I
don't really have a technique it's kind
of like in me you know right right yeah
what uh how I am I'm is natural yeah I
just figured in your career you've
learned a lot of different things that
people could learn from yeah he's a
great great filmmaker and he taught me
how to make films it's work ethic as
Laura is great and you know watching him
how he worked I mean and then you went
off into I'm being vague that's that you
like being vague no no I was making a
joke cuz I know you were thinking I was
vain
oh but were you vague huh you were
thinking of a big it's working you're
like you got me you you have now
completely completely have overtaken my
mind I'm completely debilitated now I
can't even think straight
it's it's not weird it's inspiring cuz I
feel like everyone has the ability to do
not everyone but I feel like everyone
has the choice to make to get the
ability about that so how long did it
take you to actually have this ability
on demand the Holy Spirit tells me what
you're thinking that's simple okay
I know exactly what you're thinking I
know not all the time but when I wanted
something I need to know he just tells
me he's thinking this he's thinking that
what am I thinking right now it doesn't
work like that
it don't work it's not I'm not a magic
yeah okay go ask your mom you may ask
your mother - my mom's a magician they
know we're different magicians are just
like we don't do things for pride we do
things for
purpose so if you're if you're trying to
get something out of me and learn
something the Holy Spirit's gonna tell
me what you're doing it's really I know
and so if you thought I was being vague
spirit told me this is what it is bro
this is the realness and you didn't tell
me this up but we got hot breath going
that's why you're scared they get scared
cuz that next-level stuff well I feel
you yeah man
so well I think what I think the the
nucleus of it was when you brought up
the CIA stuff and then that kind of
started me spinning out of control like
well am i CIA or does he think I'm okay
well I mean we need all the listeners we
can get yes so we'll take it
so we touch on a lot no cuz it's all if
conspiracy means it's not true I guess
right like okay this what it is this was
you know this is something that people
can say like I did a joke about guys
like that Illuminati men cut off my gas
like it was beasts and stuff you know
people almost look for an excuse so it's
not be accountable I think people don't
see what's really going on and they'd
like blame everybody else you know so
what is really going on for you to find
[Laughter]
[Music]
you're being lazy now yeah you just
you're just being lazy now you don't
want to drop any dimes on this I guess
no what is hell what is actually going
on what do you feel what do you feel is
gonna need something different than what
it was like it's like five years ago
this actual energy feels different to
you I asked you I mean it's obvious if
you have to ask him a question you might
feel that way we're wrapping up he's
just we're just going in circles right
now he's
Jedi Mind tricked me like every time I
ask something and then it like I start
to spiral into like self doubt about
even bringing up a topic it's like what
is happening this is the most bizarre
interview with John dude it's so bizarre
each other dig oh all right all I'm not
trying to but I'm saying like I don't
have any negative intent I don't think
you do so what I like would this show
you were saying I was vague like you
were you were saying I was vague well I
was asking you
you're like people just don't know
what's actually going on and I'm like
okay well what is actually going on and
then like well what do you think is
actually going on I'm like no bro I'm
asking you what the [ __ ] is going on I
don't even cuss and you're bringing out
the deal the diva Lin I literally listen
I'm will you ask me a question I'm
saying do you feel something's going on
you feel switching and everything do you
feel that you asked me and I said well
do you feel it because apparently if I'm
asking you I may feel some different
feel like the world is in a different
place don't you feel like it is okay the
game finally he's gonna drive reverse
the whole way home forever so everything
else well we went all the way to people
just don't know what's going on and they
ask you what's going on and then seven
minutes later we still don't know what's
good no one really knows so you don't
know
I'm not not for me no one really knows
everything III have a sense of I think
what's going on in the world
I feel like evil is wax and worse and
worse and that's that's what happens I
mean it's Noah so shall it be yeah
that's what it means
so I said it Oh is there anything we can
do to like reverse this started to they
got light as a thing it was a difference
these days you know no because dark is
light and light is dark no one knows
hypnotizing means like breaking through
the matrix of the mind bro this is
hilarious actually funny because you
tried to probe me and now I'm all up in
your mind but I but I have this and
there's no such thing I just want to
talk about know you got deep you ask me
these need questions you went into well
you were being vague about comedy so I
was like alright is the Illuminati real
or not
are we all dying or not is the world
ending is it is it a lost cause this is
just beginning it's just beginning
yeah man pleaded so happy this is the
greatest have you ever ran in my life is
that true I'm one of them wow I've never
seen anything it was fun yeah it was
yeah but I don't even know make it good
I had a whole road map and then I'm like
I don't know we talked about we thought
the comedy bro we did you just said I
was vague in my head and I repeated it
and you're he's like he's been real
vague that's what your spirit was saying
then that convinced me that you were
being vague instead of just being
confident in my questions I should have
just kept going that before I just
repeated what you saying it freaks you
out can you take a picture
oh no we got what we needed though you
got so much oh it's one fun it's
interviews I've ever had
why do you seem so slow I'm excited now
please don't be stressed so it was you
said this is the most fun interview what
ever had yes I'm anima I'm not mad
either I'm just like I'm exhausted I'm
not mad I'm exhausted more energy I know
cuz you're taking it from me no no this
was good song so so yeah I mean before
we get out of here is there anything
else you want the world to know kingdom
of everything productions coming soon
kingdom of everything we're doing movies
gonna inspire the world and have them
feel exhausted like you know as
faith-based yes / Aish you know
faith-based everything's gonna be things
that's gonna you know be a light in the
dark place right now I think we need
some positivity you know mm-hmm well I'm
happy to be a part of that positive
please oh great I know you're confused
tell me I'm complete I'm not confused
totally in control and comfortable right
now I'm not uncomfortable at all okay
two dreams okay and you know some of the
stuff will make sense and and and why
this interview was so bizarre
I'm gonna have two dreams tonight yes
that explain what happened you're not
fully it'll confirmed that that what we
did to name is everything that you were
trying to probe and everything will will
will be confirmed in your way of going
why do I feel so like after this
interview
well like you mentioning bringing
positivity back yes the world is there
anything listeners or viewers is there
something that they can do to help start
to bring that positivity back
honestly I think you need to search the
truth and see what what the truth is for
you and then question that and then go
back and and research more and then keep
just keep digging because I think
everyone finds what what their truth is
in in in their hearts and in their souls
and I think that there's only one truth
but it's up to the person to find that
one truth Jimmy tips on finding the
truth like researching it you said yeah
there was an old book back in the day
that we used to read humanity you know
some scrolls that were taken from
ancient people mmm like myself they were
called prophets you know gods oh okay I
think we're getting back today I think I
think we're is about that time where
people don't either like just say it's
fully BS or is fully real we're gonna
really see if it's real it's fake
tonight I'm gonna see tonight when I
dream good for you you understand how it
works man I got to tell you what the
will the fact you're even willing to sit
down and do this interview this is the
best interview ever had in my life one
of not deep can you say hot breath is
one of the best interviews I've ever had
oh this is definitely hot breath this
was some hot hot hot breath hot breath
was one of the best interviews I've ever
had shut up we're here relax right now
we haven't smoked no weed no and we feel
like we're so high on a cloud and we
have not smoked
nothing oh my gosh you described it
perfectly actually yeah I'd be asleep if
it was contact may be game over for me
well yeah thanks for taking a let me
know
boom alright brandon t jackson think
spilling hot breath thank you bro thanks
for having me a breath
[Music]
[Music]
I breath
you